bien
madame
la Première ministre
madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale monsieur le ministre chargé
des Relations avec le Parlement
dans mes messieurs les ministres
monsieur le Président du Conseil
constitutionnel monsieur le
vice-président du Conseil d'État
monsieur le Président du conseiller
économique social et environnemental
de l'Assemblée nationale monsieur le
Kester de l'Assemblée nationale
Mesdames et Messieurs les vices
présidents du Sénat mes chers collègues
puisque les questeurs du Sénat Mesdames
et Messieurs les secrétaires du bureau
du Cénac qui vous ont accueilli avec les
vices présidents et les quaisseurs
Mesdames et Messieurs les présidents de
commissions
madame et Messieurs les Présidents de
groupe
Mesdames et Messieurs les Présidents de
délégation et Office parlementaires
Monsieur le Secrétaire général de
l'Amicale du Sénat et chers anciens
collègues mais chers collègues Monsieur
le Secrétaire général du Sénat madame la
secrétaire général de la question
mesdames et messieurs les membres de
cabinets mesdames et messieurs
merci oui merci
à toutes et tous pour votre présence ce
soir au Sénat
mes collègues sénatrices sénateurs et
moi-même nous sommes collectivement
heureux de vous accueillir pour célébrer
cette année nouvelle
voici donc le temps des voeux
occasion de nous retrouver et de vous
accueillir madame la Première ministre
madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale
l'année qui s'achève aura été le théâtre
de bouleversement
géopolitique politique économique
et Laura était difficile entre la crise
sanitaire la poussée de l'inflation et
ses conséquences sur le pouvoir d'achat
de nos compatriotes et la compétitivité
de nos entreprises oui
la France de janvier 2023 est une France
qui s'interroge qui doute parfois
il y a bien sûr les crises
conjoncturelles auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés crise de l'énergie et ses
conséquences crises sanitaire
il y a les réformes qui se profilent
personnellement je les juges nécessaires
même si certaines susciteront des
mobilisations sociales et des débats
passionnés je pense notamment pour les
semaines à venir à la réforme des
retraites
il y a des réformes structurelles qu'il
faut engager sans tarder
je veux évoquer la maîtrise de notre
dépense publique l'école et notre
système de santé entre crise de
l'hôpital et désert médicaux santé qui
est sans doute l'une des premières
préoccupations de nos concitoyens et de
nos élus sur le territoire
il faut maintenant
redonner de l'espérance
et reconstruire une relation de
confiance avec les Français
si nous posons dans notre diversité
un diagnostic assez comparable nous
différen parfois sur les solutions
apportées et nous devons nous écouter
nous enrichir de ces différences c'est
le fonctionnement normal d'une
démocratie représentative d'ailleurs
entre majorité et opposition la majorité
doit être attentive respectueuse des
différences et l'opposition doit être
certes sans complaisance mais
responsables
le Parlement débat propose et amende la
loi il la vote il contrôle le
gouvernement dans le respect des
sensibilités qui le composent il est une
force de proposition qui trace des
perspectives d'avenir
cette fonction de représentation cette
vitalité démocratique moi qui croient au
rôle du Parlement que la Cinquième
République a imaginé doit être conforté
en juin dernier
constatons la nouvelle réalité de la
représentation des forces politiques
issues des élections législatives j'ai
souhaité une révolution culturelle tant
de la part du gouvernement que du
Parlement dans la manière de préparer de
conduire les relations entre exécutif et
législatif cela s'appelle pour moi le
dialogue préalable et cela ne préonte
nullement le débat et le droit
d'amendement qui est un droit
fondamental
il faut mettre en place je dirais enfin
je m'adresse à nous tous une sobriété
législative
nous légiférons trop
nous n'avons pas toujours de réelles
études d'impact nous évaluons que trop
peu
nous devons nous devons de part et
d'autre réfléchir à cette complexité
législative à cette complexité
réglementaire
devenue un empilement
incompréhensible pour les citoyens et
parfois quasi inapplicable pour les
magistrats
madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale
pour que le bulk amérisme fonctionne
mieux il faut que les deux chambres aux
compétences partagées et au rôle
complémentaire dialogue entre elles dans
un esprit positif je vous remercie
sincèrement divin
nous avons des débats nous pouvons avoir
des différences mais au fond la
République nous rassemble
le Sénat et la chambre des territoires
la France s'est diverses c'est une
richesse et un atout
l'initiative locale est souvent une
source d'inspiration pour les politiques
publiques nationales je crois
profondément à la créativité de nos
territoires il faut les accompagner en
leur donnant enfin de l'autonomie
financière et fiscale et en respectant
la liberté l'initiative des élus locaux
leur liberté de créer d'expérimenter
d'entreprendre
il nous faut lever les freins et les
pesanteurs qui ralentissent leurs
initiatives et entravent l'efficacité
des politiques publiques qu'il
conduisent
en un mot il faut aussi là restaurer la
confiance dans leur relation avec l'État
alors il est temps d'écrire cette grande
loi de décentralisation de liberté
locale le président de la République va
revenir en septembre dernier une loi qui
permettra de libérer les énergies et
d'arrêter de priver progressivement les
communes notamment de leur liberté
d'action
ce n'est pas que d'un texte de
répartition nouvelles de compétences de
réorganisation de l'État ou
d'organisation différenciée de nos
territoires dans une République une et
indivisible dont nous avons besoin c'est
plus que cela c'est à une nouvelle
architecture de la responsabilité et de
la décision que j'appelle cela s'appelle
liberté cela rompt avec la verticalité
il faut en quelque sorte se refonder il
faut oser tout simplement cette nouvelle
architecture le Sénat la prépare c'est
d'ailleurs sa vocation il a engagé un
travail concret sur la décentralisation
les libertés locales la différenciation
c'est sa mission constitutionnelle de
représentants des territoires nous avons
installé le 5 octobre dernier au Sénat
le groupe de travail pluraliste sur la
décentralisation des libertés locales
ces conclusions seront rendues publiques
au printemps
madame la Première ministre
j'évoquais il y a un instant les vertus
du bicaméricisme je voudrais peut-être
aussi ce soir
rappeler le rôle stabilisateur du Sénat
dans les institutions
aucune démocratie ne peut être
réellement vivante sans contre-pouvoir
institutionnel ce contre peut voir si tu
channel c'est toujours lui de Sénat sans
doute un peu plus hors des pulsions du
moment des excès ou des confrontations
idéologiques qui peuvent dénaturer le
débat parlementaire non je vous le dis à
tous mais vous en êtes tous persuadés le
Parlement n'est pas une ZAD je vous le
dis extrêmement clairement
il peut parfois être un lieu de débat
passionné mais il doit aussi être le
lieu du discernement et de la raison
au Sénat
c'est cet esprit de responsabilité qui
nous anime c'est l'intérêt du pays c'est
l'attachement sans faille aux valeurs
que nous portons et à la République
je le répète une indivisible et laïque
vous diront oui si sincèrement nous
pensons que c'est utile pour nos
compatriotes c'est utile pour la France
nous dirons non à chaque fois qu'il le
faudra le Sénat sera relayé les
difficultés parfois la détresse de ceux
qui se sentent oubliés ce que j'ai
souvent qualifié de français de la
France d'à côté
je voudrais aussi
vous dire combien nous ressentons au
travers de nos contacts avec les élus
les acteurs associatifs la montée de la
précarité
une région de rencontre avec la
présidente
a été pour moi
éclairante j'allais dire presque
révélatrice il y a quelque chose nous
devons y être attentifs
si nous sommes préoccupés aussi
par la qualité de l'air attention à ce
tiers de Français qui vont dans les
trois ans est exclu par la loi de
l'accès au cœur des grandes
agglomérations ceci me préoccupe
beaucoup il va falloir que nous y
réfléchissons collective
nous serons
attentifs à nous outre-mer tout comme
vous madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale je me rendrai en Martinique et
en Guadeloupe à la fin de la semaine
prochaine
je crois
au rôle de la diplomatie parlementaire
au travers notamment de notre commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées au travers de la
commission pour les affaires européennes
au travers des groupes d'amitié dans
lesquels nos collègues s'impliquent
pleinement
je me suis rendu depuis le mois de
juillet en Ukraine
tout comme vous récemment en Serbie et
au Vietnam
le Sénat recevra de nouveau le président
de la radar ukrainienne le premier
février prochain tout comme l'Assemblée
nationale
l'agression de l'Ukraine par la Russie
a remis en cause deux décennies de paix
et d'équilibre de sécurité collective
pour l'ensemble de l'Europe
la démontré à la fois le caractère
essentiel de la cohésion de l'Union
européenne et renforcer l'OTAN
notre pays dans son rôle important et
une militaire et assistance humanitaire
à l'Ukraine au Sénat nous accompagnons
la Rada dans la démarche de candidature
à l'Union européenne
j'avoue aussi mon inquiétude sur
l'évolution de nos relations avec une
partie de l'Afrique et de notre présence
sur ce continent avec lequel nous avons
tant de liens historiques culturel et
humain fort
je voudrais avoir devant vous ce soir
une pensée solidaire pour l'Arménie et
les Arméniens avoir une pensée toute
particulière pour les Iraniennes et les
Iraniens qui se battent pour leur
liberté avec un courage exceptionnel
en Europe il nous faudra travailler à
l'émergence oui de cette Europe plus
indépendante plus forte plus efficace je
pense au rétablissement de sa
souveraineté dans un monde en pleine
mutation où les économistes protègent et
où le multilatéralisme s'affaiblit nous
pensions vivre dans un monde libre
échange il semble que nous assistions
aujourd'hui à la grande revanche d'une
certaine forme de protectionnisme
mais veut s'adresse à vous mes chers
collègues
mes chers collègues sénateurs vous qui
enrichissez nos débats de vous
interventions et de vos travaux de votre
action sur le terrain en métropole dans
nos outre-mer et auprès de nos
compatriotes établis hors de France il
s'adresse à mes collègues membres du
bureau et de la Conférence des
Présidents avec qui nous partageons le
souci commun de l'institution
sénatoriale oui chacune et chacun
d'entre vous vous participez à cette
vitalité du mi-camiris et à notre
mission de représentation démocratique
grâce à vous n'exigence législative du
Sénat a été au rendez-vous de 2022 et
notre Assemblée a imprimer sa marque sur
un certain nombre de textes qu'il s'agit
du projet de loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère d'intérieur
du projet de loi relatif à
l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable est en cours et
nous avons débuté le nucléaire cet
après-midi mais aussi du projet de loi
de programmation des finances publiques
au point qu'il est d'ailleurs toujours
en examen
je vous donnerai une explication grâce à
vous le Sénat
a fait entendre savoir lors de l'examen
du projet de loi de finance comme sur le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale mais nous aurions dû
être mieux écouté
madame la Première ministre si les
mesures d'accompagnement des
collectivités territoriales et des
entreprises je pense notamment plus
petites d'entre elles sont
indispensables pour les protégés de
l'augmentation des coûts de l'énergie il
faut éviter les complexités d'un certain
nombre de dispositifs qui les rendent
trop souvent très peu compréhensible et
parfois inaccessible permettez-moi en
ces temps de vœux de formuler ce vœux là
de mesures simples compréhensibles
audible et partagée
très bientôt nous aurons à examiner la
réforme que vous proposez madame la
Première ministre pour notre système de
retraite
elle ne paraît pas très éloignée de ce
que propose avec constance et dans un
esprit de dialogue la majorité
sénatoriale depuis 4 années je souhaite
un débat
et je le dis à tous quel que soit quel
que soit votre position y compris depuis
quatre ans sur ce sujet qui aille au
fond de ce qui est un pilier de notre
modèle social
il nous faudra échapper aux postures
au blocage pour répondre aux inquiétudes
aux questions elles sont nombreuses de
nos concitoyens sur un sujet
particulièrement difficile
il semble que la réforme de nos
institutions soit de nouveau à l'ordre
du jour au cours de ce quinquennat
nous y sommes prêts nous avons déjà
travaillé nous continuons à le faire le
groupe de travail transpartisans a été
mis en place au Sénat ces propositions
permettront d'enrichir le débat et
préciseront la position des sénateurs
sur l'amélioration du fonctionnement de
notre démocratie et bien faire elle
présenteront les évolutions nous
jugerons utiles pour reconstruire ce
lien de confiance avec les Français mais
attention à la juste représentation des
territoires
et au respect de nos équilibres
constitutionnels là encore
ne touchons pas à la constitution au gré
des émotions fut-elles légitimes ou des
conventions
madame la Première ministre madame la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale mes
chers collègues
la France la France est un grand pays
qui a su traverser des crises des
conflits qui a subi des traumatismes la
France a toujours su les surmonter je
crois
en notre capacité de résilience je crois
qu'il les nul difficulté que les
Français ne puissent surmonter je crois
en nous soignants qui affrontent les
difficultés avec courage et dévouement
je crois à l'engagement associatif
facteur de cohésion je crois en nos
forces de sécurité qui chaque jour
protègent les Français je crois en nous
forces armées qui ont payé un lourd
tribu dans la lutte contre le djihadisme
je crois à l'engagement des enseignants
pour transmettre les savoirs je crois à
la capacité d'innovation et d'adaptation
de nos chefs d'entreprises et de nos
chercheurs tout simplement je crois je
crois en la France alors à chacune et à
chacun d'entre vous très bonne année
pleine d'espérance très bonne année
au gouvernement madame la Première
ministre très bonne année à l'Assemblée
nationale et nous avons un même ministre
qui veille sur nous monsieur le ministre
on cherche des relations avec le
Parlement oui oui très bonne année au
Sénat très bonne année à la France merci
[Applaudissements]